c'est un australien tristane school kate
qui s'impose en finale du tournoi
international futur du tennis club de
plaisir 2021 un match remporté 6 4 7 5
en 1h35 de jeu face au français
alexandre ricaud un titre obtenu tout en
maîtrise par l'australien malgré les
difficultés du terrain j'ai beaucoup
joué sur terrain dur en extérieur en
transpirant énormément aux états unis
mais aussi sur les terres battues
d'europe c'est un très gros challenge de
jouer en salle sur du dur c'est plus
rapide j'ai dû bien servir bien retourné
je suis beaucoup monté au filet j'ai
joué beaucoup de volets je pense que
c'est ce qui m'a aidé à gagner cette
semaine la finale face au jeune français
alexandre ricaud était loin d'être
gagnée d'avancé pour l'australien le
tennisman de 22 ans était la surprise de
la semaine c'est un petit français qui
étaient dans les qualifications et qui a
traversé les qualifs qui a traversé le
tableau final et qui a perdu en finale
mais c'est quand même une belle nageurs
de ces jeunes alexandre qui a fait un
parcours merveilleux les supporters
étaient bien sûr toujours derrière lui
beaucoup d'applaudissements beaucoup de
bruit on a l'impression d'être l'ennemi
c'est super de gagner le match et je
suis très soulagé d'avoir remporté ce
titre comme récompense pour l'australien
de 20 ans cette 135e mondiale un chèque
de 25 mille dollars et quelques points
au classement atp qui lui permettront
peut-être d'être invités à des tournois
encore plus prestigieux